hello everybody my name is markiplier
I'm here with yamimash hello everyone oh
my gosh yamimash and we are playing
slimy Toby's but we're playing the
versus mode till I am tinky-winky and
I'm going to murder his ass it's never
fair why am I never tell you Toby always
chicken
yo can be it next time whenever we do
this I know people will want to see this
again but anyway oh great oh here I got
a catch-up cuz I started way on the
other side of the map here where are you
Oh ten I beat you that's pretty much
yeah yes yeah I don't know how I'm I see
you you see me I see you oh [ __ ] okay
where you goin there buddy are you high
where are you going oh you're running
out for some custard you know what I
could do I could like scout out the
custard tell you which direction to go
try and help you now as you go right go
right turn right
yeah go straight there straight straight
right there yeah you got it yeah yeah
see I'm helping and now I'm done helping
forever
just the one coaster screaming happen
yeah it's really loud I can't tell what
I'm doing do you
I'm just kind of floating around you
you're headed toward the house if you
take like two degrees to the right
you'll be going straight to the house
wait another one degree to the left
you hit honey way to go okay and you're
going right to the house yes in turn
right yes I wish I could make that
happen
Oh fun I like this I like this mode yeah
you'll play it next time down the road a
bit
whatever you didn't go in the house I
think you need three custards at least
oh okay you have two too bad
won't get those three custards yeah well
Eastern fire you you know you you don't
know that I've been like inches behind
you this entire time if you turn around
feet hyemi the screaming will start Oh
custard right there don't go friend I'm
tell you right this way alright I don't
know what's ahead of you let me just
wait if I run past you
nah dude does it still scream if I'm not
facing you
you're so screaming okay huh
there doesn't seem to be anything this
way you are I'm just gonna try and find
the house again mmm oh wait custard to
your left immediately 90 degrees aha oh
you're a good tinky-winky bard I hear
you're the greatest
um tinky-winky don't do the mountains of
nothingness oh [ __ ] yeah sorry I'm gonna
go Scout off in different locations mmm
you know this is not how it's supposed
to go no no you want me to be evil yeah
we'll keep doing this we'll keep you in
this where'd you go where'd you go I
don't know you went to the mountains of
nothingness you know the problem is the
the custer's don't disappear maybe order
the same location and they wait that
they stay on your screen damn it much I
don't know what makes the doors open
yeah I'm done helping you for now you're
on your own
yeah that's so sad for you can you see
me right now
no you seriously on top of that oh my
god I could jump through here yeah oh
you can huh Wow I got the custards oh
well how are you gonna get out I'm
through the door hope yeah there we go
are you laughing cuz I can can you see
me from where you are no no I'm on yes
how far does the screaming work yeah
Chuck on that she said jokes I wasn't
screaming you're heading to the
mountains of nothingness
yeah lose me on the mountaintop
I got no you can't I would find you
never find me of this mountain Wow I can
climb really well
shame oh I don't even have to jump to
climb up I'll find you
I'm inside the mountain that will find
you
don't you worry there yamimash I will
come for you ah no I won't cuz I can't
climb ah I lost you you have where the
hell did you go awesome
where'd you go I must say hey where'd
you go I'm by some trees and grass if
that'll help you grass no I wish I could
send those jumpscares your way balls
I had an invisible wall hey where'd you
go yes there you go you're stealing all
your customer yeah you won't take my
custard muscle nd custard fix ladies
faces await mmm I don't know what that
means but okay alright fine cursed I'm
headed to the lake no don't go to the
lake I haven't taught that one yet so do
the lake you can you can stay on your
Mountain all you want play friends no
yeah yeah I'll find you again down the
road I don't know how to kill you cuz
I've stood in front of you for quite a
bit maybe you just can't kill me oh yeah
is that a challenge yeah are you still
on the mountains now not anions anymore
okay where'd you go a bit bored of them
where'd you go then I don't see you
anywhere I'm not too sure which
direction I'm giving that's if it'll
help I might be on the pathway need
blood Slendy toffee need blood where'd
you go are you at the lake no I escaped
get you woman a 14 you inky was a woman
oh sorry
I'm on your ankle bones this is a total
tinky-winky nurse my floppy tummy boobs
auntie Slendy a hug no I've completely
lost you and I could like see forever
how did I lose you I'm just my pan in a
360 do I find you
then it's like Oh locked on target
you're running away from your dummy
custard burger [ __ ] don't even try to go
for the cave no not the mountain ruler
I'm like so close to you huh how do I
get you
Oh am I where am I I don't know
yo do you see where I am no I've got its
side the mountain of Ganesha inside the
boundaries I'm gonna consider that a
victory for me I can't either
wha-at not even fair you cheating
bastard
God that means I win you can't come on
[ __ ] ah that's not fair so happy right
now
yo cheated they custer's did you have
before you broke the game seven custards
Wow
do you and all your custards I had you I
had you on the ropes well I think this
uh yes alright fine this is a worthy
opponent I suppose so thank you all so
much for watching check out on yami
masters channel of the other cop we did
a flirty Toby's as actually trying to
work together which didn't work out
either so thank you all so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video okay you're gonna go left
right there's a large oil portion on the
right
[Music]
hey scotches man don't [ __ ] Oh God